Hey ladies gentlemen before we do
another thing is there a doctor in the
house
why yes there is doctor Will Ferrell Wow
[Applause]
the University of Southern California oh
gosh is my university in Los Angeles and
I received an honorary Doctorate they
say its honoree I think it's for real
I've performed 13 successful surgeries
and a hundred that didn't go so well so
I'm currently I have a lot of
malpractice issues these things you have
to make the kind of the inspirational
speech so what did you tell the young
people I yeah it I hadn't been put in
that position before because usually I
just make fun of things right and and
that's that's easy but then you have to
be earnest and yeah that was that was a
difficult task but so I just told them
to keep your feet firmly planted on the
ground and reach for the stars which I
read on the back of a cereal box took a
very unexpected turn I feel at the end
yes yes no I thought I would inspire the
graduating class by singing a Whitney
Houston song today which one did you
choose will the theme from The Bodyguard
yes I would always love you yes and now
pretty you sang the whole thing I
started thinking do I just sing a couple
of lines or do I torture the students
and their parents by singing the entire
song and I chose the latter
he's not going to be having that this is
just a tiny clip if you actually good
you say your brother cool Oh
[Music]
well
[Music]
did you see me look down to try to
remember the words
love you
[Music]